hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the feeder Grand Prix 2019
again we are in the tiebreaks this is
the well after the two class programs
have been drawn then Duda took the lead
by winning the first rapid game then
agree should be equalized by winning the
second second rapid game and now we
entered the faster rapid games these are
the 10 minutes plus 10 10 minutes plus
10 seconds increments so much faster
than than the previous time format and
it's just a crazy crazy attacking game
so I do hope you enjoy it without
further ado let's check it out three
shook with the white pieces opens width
d4 we have d5 c4 and c6 now a bit of a
bit of a refreshment from from the
previous lines Knight f3 Knight to f6
and now III we have E six and Bishop to
d3 by Grisham we have Knight B to d7 and
now b3 we have B 6 and now comes Castle
Swagger issue we have a bishop to b-17
catering the light square Bishop Bishop
to b2 and now D captures on c4 will be
captures on c4 and now c5 releasing the
dark square bishop so everything is you
know in order and here there is one game
where knife to c3 was played but the d5
is a new move by Grisha and again
English is starting some commotion right
right right from the start the black
king is still in the middle of the board
so naturally you want to open lines with
each captures on d5 see captures on d5
and Bishop captures on d5 again the
issue of sacrifice is a point for some
nice activity he has the bishop pair
still and he bushes efore he wants to
push efore a5 and keep the king in the
center of the board as long as possible
we have Bushnell back to c6 and now rook
to e1 preparing to push he five and here
you can ax you kind of want to play nice
to h5 it looks ugly but you have to
clear the knight from from f6 as a5 is
coming but here Queen to e7 is played by
do that he wants the Castle queenside as
soon as possible but a good issue has
something for that as well we have nice
to see three now preparing to bring the
knight over to d5 if you keep your queen
and king aligned that one knights the d5
comes then it's it's just game over so
here we have Queen
castle getting the King to safety as
soon as possible and now Knight to d5
attacking so of course you don't want to
trade and open up the rooks attack to
the Queen
so Queen back to e8 and now a four of
course agree she wants to attack on the
Queen side as soon as possible with
Bishop to d6 and now comes Bishop to a
sex with check first King to be eight
and now Queen to b3 saying I don't need
the e4 point you can have it I'm gonna
continue with my attack do that grabs d4
pawn we have Knight captures on e4 and
now comes a five so what do you do here
here do that missed an opportunity to
slow down with ashok's attack a bit with
c4 give up a pawn at least move the
Queen away from the B file after Queen
captures go Queen e6 have a double
attack against the night here it would
it would definitely slow down
Sasha's attack but here do that went to
Bishop to c7 instead adding another
defender to the b6 pawn but this creates
more problems for Duda than it solves
a capture some b6 with a capture Sun b6
and now Bishop to b5 opening up the a
file for the Queen and Queen Quinta a
for 287 is the idea also the c6 Bishop
is under attack and well if you play
something like Bishop captures here then
Queen captures your you're getting made
it here so not something you want to do
so Duda just moves back the Bishop
Bishop to b7 but now Queen to a4 going
for a 7 here we have Queen to e6 and now
comes our remarkable move by Grisha I
really enjoyed this move really just
just a beauty here Grisha played you can
even pause the video and maybe try to
figure out what he played if you want
I'll give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it if
you found rocked d1 that's that's an
excellent move if you found a queen to
a7 check that's an excellent move but
the move grisha plate is just a beauty
good if you played Bishop to c6 and this
is just this is just a WoW move
especially for such a quick game the
point is the bishop cannot be captured
if you capture with the bishop then the
c7 Bishop is no longer guarded Queen e7
check King c8 and Queen
c7 is mate but it's even nicer if the
Queen captures then you no longer have
control over the e7 squared then it's
Queen a7 check King c8 and now Knight to
e7 a nice modern mate
so Bishop to c6 just just a beautiful
move so how do you defend here well do
defines a very nice idea he vacates the
c7 square for the king he plays Bishop
captures an h2 now that the King has an
escape route then Queen captures on e6
and c6 will be possible because there is
no Knight to e7 mate at the end of this
line because Queen to c7 is just a king
to c7 just escapes so we should capture
the bishop we have Queen captures and c6
now offering a trade here but of course
Sasha does not allow this ruling to a7
check King to c8 and the now Knight the
e7 check with with winning the Queen
although we don't really win the Queen
because well after King to c7 Sasha
grabbed the Queen but now comes looked a
8 trapping trapping his Queen as well so
what do you play here certain plays rook
captures on e4 we have rook captures an
a7 and now rook captures an a7 with King
captures and c6 and now just rook to e7
so at the end of this in entire line you
can see that Sasha is up a whole rook
and if this was any normal game of
course Duda would resign this but he's
fighting for the for the 1st place in
the Phaedo grand prix so do that says
okay I have to connect the past pawns
here I'm just gonna I'm just gonna try
and make something out of them even
though even though Grisha gives up a
whole rook so ok we have looked to d8
bringing the rook into the game and then
now Knight back Knight to f3 you can
always start picking up the King side
pawns not not much black can do about
this
we have b5 starting to push those passed
pawns and now rook captures on f7
we have before rook captures Ang's do
that putting all of his hopes in those
two connect bones maybe something good
will come out of it
Bishop sorry looking to b6 pushing the
rug back rook to a-1 and now Bishop
captures on f3 Trading even further as
now griffix pawn structure is ruined and
he only has he's only upper rook that
that's only it is only up
rook so nice the f8 guarding the h7 pawn
and now look the g8 attacking the denied
preparing to attack the pin piece we
have c4 continuing to push the past
points and now Bishop to g7 here you
don't have a choice you have to trade
further night here to defend the rook
but now rook captures Knight captures
and rook the c1 attacking the c4 pawn
king to b5 so still up a whole rook but
you do have to connect past points it
could be could be dangerous if those
pawns get here then it could be a
problem a grecian plays F for his pawn
is also a passed pawn so why not push it
we have night to e6 attacking the bishop
and the pawn and Bishop to e5 getting
rid of both threats Knights the c5 and
now comes King to f1 Sasha starts to
bring the King into the game nights to
d3 attacking the bishop and the rook but
just looked at e1 it's not a problem
King the c5 now comes King e2 we have
Kings to d5 and not rook the h1 saying
that okay if you capture here it's not a
problem
we can we can just trade everything I'm
gonna capture eh so in point and my king
and rook will be plenty to prevent your
two connected passed pawns
so Knight back the c5 by Judah now comes
Luke captures on h7 we have C 3 and here
sasha was a very long time and he didn't
like those pawns marching forward too
quickly so he decided to give back some
material bishop capture since e3 was
played be captures and now rook the c7
just pressuring the night here also if
the knight moves you might be able to
grab the c3 pawn we have c2 and kinked
d2 defending so what do you play here
well you could play a lot of things for
example night the c3 chick is very
interesting but the problem is you just
capture the c2 point so nothing really
happens there if you couldn't capture
them it would be a problem so nice the
e4 check is played we have King captures
and c2 and the Knight captures on f2 so
here it's a rook and pawn against the
night completely winning for white but
still the the stakes are too high and do
that we'll give it or give it his all we
have kinked up efore now comes King e2
attacks the knight Knight g4 and do not
look the c4 with check King f5 now
King to f3 Knight h2 check King goes to
g2 knight goes back to g4 King g3 slowly
but surely making progress
Knights to e3 attacking the rogue but
rook c5 trick King f6 and the now kink
to f3 pushing the knight back King at
five and now rook to a5 not morning you
look anywhere near the night so we don't
have to calculate all the forks so here
just the rock is on the edge of the
board
no no trickery there King g6 we have
worked the a6 with check and it was in
this position unmoved 60 that young
shift of Duda resigned the game and now
it's Grisha who takes the lead in the
tournament putting Duda in a must-win
situation so there is one more quick
rapid game left
so if Duda is not able to retaliate it's
a Greek who will win the feeder Grand
Prix here you just resign because it's
um well slowly but surely wife will make
progress let's say king e4 Knight has to
move somewhere like the king is 7 and
now you can even give up the rook for
the night because after any move by
black you can just capture capture and
voila a king e5 you have the opposition
you're winning the endgame so now after
this rook to a6 check do the resigned
and for the first time in the match
Grisha takes the lead and it's well now
it's Duda who's in a very unpleasant
position he has to win the game
otherwise it's game over for him yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
I would like to thank James done Henry
Campbell a piotrowska vronsky goku ji
and tower morgan for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot - really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos sierra think all
for watching and i will see you soon
definitely continuing the coverage of
the feeder grand prix and of course as
usual checking up on your wonderful
suggestions so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your Sunday